[Music]
so my name is avishai bernoy and I'm a
PhD student at Tel Aviv University for
biophysics I have a master's in
chemistry from the Hebrew University
and today I will talk to you about my
side project that helps me choose what
to eat for dinner
so what's my problem as a human being I
need to eat every day to sust well I
need to eat because I need to do things
in my life like you know live
um so I need to choose what to eat not
just cook it so
um
what I used to do as a bachelor Bachelor
student I used to make this huge spot on
Sunday and eat it for five straight days
well unfortunately I married us someone
and I fell in love with her and she told
me that this course of action with fits
Psychopaths
um and I should not do it so now we came
up with you know feeding two mouths and
you know things came around now we have
two kids they're cute but they also need
sustenance so now we need to fit form
out so we need so instead of you know
this thing I did with with taking off
this mental load by cooking one
now I need to cook for four people
things that all four would like to eat
and you know have this variety and
that's again puts a lot of mental load
on our life
another thing you need to know is that
me and my wife have very demanding jobs
and being a PhD student she works at the
NGO so by the time we come home we're
already exhausted
we we like we need to we have so many
tax to do tests to do at home so we're
we're just
stumped so
an additional thing that I love is I
love over solving simple problems like
taking some painting a small lay on
hitting it with the biggest hammer I can
find the second thing is I like
overselling simple jokes so what
happened is that on Twitter uh I came
out what should I make for dinner so I
pretended to be a bot and I was like
um these people will tag me and I will
tell them make this make that make this
and then I came up okay maybe that's a
joke but maybe I can make this
um and I like knitting and if you want
to know why I wrote it because please
referred to the previous Bulletin
um okay so what I did
um I went down and wrote down everything
about what we like to eat for dinner
um everything in a CSV file so
um what we like to eat how much do we
like it we I got like about 40 meals but
name in Hebrew in English
um a recipe suggestion how long does it
take to cook how long does it take to
cut on The Cutting Board
everything and they're like a bunch of
features in that file so now that I have
the database I can go on and describe
the the project called Deep cook
um so
what I did is I on top of that
of the database I wrote down uh
functions that take that they call from
that database and return objects and the
importance of taking off of returning
objects is now you know as as the same
paper person I you know my wife
described I work on Linux just terminal
and I also code in Vim that's where I
write my my code
um the same thing to do
um so
um now that I have my CLI I can you know
I can go on it type the fungus python
whatever and get the suggestion right
and do I want to do it when I make it
and then well what if God forbids my
wife wants to call to use it then I had
to to generate a web a web app which is
which I use streamlit which is extremely
easy way to publish your data app it's
written through Python and it's free and
it puts it on the internet which is
amazing and now comes the question why
now with GPT chat and you know Google
that's been out for a new couple of
years
why would deep cook be needed like why
isn't out of sleep and the reason is is
that this solves my problem this takes
off my mental load because if I go on
the GPT chat and ask it what should I
make for dinner give me a recipe I still
need to assess
how long will people in my family eat
this do I have the ingredients
so although general purpose models and
and search engines solve my problem
solve a problem they don't solve my
specific problem
that's it thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]